好 我差不多開始吧
我覺得上週還沒有講完
然後這一週 這兩週市場其實波動非常的大
然後大家其實比較關心的幾個問題
特別是有槓桿盤在陳儲上面
就受傷會特別大
然後大家比較關心的幾個問題
第一個就是這個事情為什麼會發生
然後持續可能會多久
接著接下去發展會怎麼樣
我覺得其實先簡單來講
一個就是回到陳儲的問題
其實這次下調不光是陳儲
在各個方面
就所有的AI相關的公司
我們叫做Momentum
這些Momentum就是
我們其實在買那個所有半導體
都算是Momentum
就等於是我在買這些AI相關的
在上漲的
然後我們在跟隨這個趨勢
那麼這些Momentum也在被平倉
這個是過去兩個星期的主機調
然後這個機調有幾個階段
然後包括我們後面前講的有可能的發展
就首先我說一個觀點
就是跌了最兇的比方說陳儲
因為這個是陳儲拉動他下跌的
陳儲我從來沒覺得陳儲
應該拿到皮的物質
也就是我也沒覺得陳儲這些公司
他業績會變差
他業績不太會變差
除了星期一的時候
有一些鬼故事在講Henix
大家海裡市業績可能因為HVM做了多
他質量高
但是RAM也不急於急
但本質上所有陳儲公司業績
這兩年都會很好
但是大家可能就是會看得到
像過去兩星期的這樣
我們叫做估值的大幅的波動
這個估值大幅波動
在未來一年兩年裡面
在半導體裡
我覺得會持續的發生
這肯定不是第一次
也不會是最猛烈的一次
會來回的發生
那麼最主要原因其實很簡單
我覺得這件事情
我們在上上周
我上次做視頻的時候和之前
來回都講過
就原因很簡單的就是要融資
所以你在高位套現資產的過程當中
你就會造成Momentum Trade的踩踏
這個Momentum Trade踩踏
中國的投資人可能比較熟悉
我先說一下原因
中國投資人可能比較熟悉
就跟昨天我一個朋友跟我講
中正2000
中正2000今年跌了很多
然後對於秒數呼聲300跌
一樣道理
有大量的量化機構在中國去買小票
買那些高增長小票業績確實都很好
然後買高增長業績非常好的小票
然後他們可能另外一個Lack在做工指數
然後當他們的倉位全部一致性的時候
有任何風吹草動
導致有一部分的倉位平出來
就大家都要平
平的時候你會導致原來那些老登資產就漲
然後新興資產就暴跌
然後去高難時的暴跌
那這就是Momentum Trade
Momentum Trade存在於不同的形式吧
它不光是我們說的long show lag
比如說我們之前講過
市場上非常受歡迎的買半導體
然後賣出買半導體存儲為主
然後賣出那個比方說軟件
然後認為軟件是被替代型資產
賣IGV
那其實它也可以純買半導體
它也可以買半導體做空
比如說微軟
或者是做空retail
或者是做空apple
都可以
這都是Momentum Trade
這樣的Trade在市場上非常大
我就有兩個概念
我在之前直接講到過
然後我的判斷
可能稍微有點失誤等
就檢討一下
就回顧一下這個事情
一個是我們認為Gross margin非常的高
這個數據可能我沒有放在BPD上
這個Gross margin在最高的時候到300%
Net margin不高
Net margin在50%左右
那麼我當時的認為
也是市場上有多空不同的分歧的觀點
因為市場不確定性
有多空不同的分歧的觀點
我們說到底是漲還是跌
後面會有一個確定的方向
然後Net margin一直在降
Gross margin其實也降了挺多的
其實在4月份的時候又開始下降
但是整體的水平還是算是比較高
之前到300%
但這個我現在回顧這東西
很有可能就是有大量的parody trade
我們叫parody trade就是
它本身這個基金裡面
在買路的半導體
同時的話它賣出其他東西
所以在半導體裡面
在半導體和AI相關資產
我們叫AI相關資產
這個不光是半導體
包括比方說Neocloud
就是Covif
Nambulance那些公司
包括他們
包括可能和電相關的
包括晶圓廠
包括Fabulous
包括國王村
其實都算是momentum的資產
就是這個資產端
就這個資產端
它是槓桿非常嚴高
那麼第二個
我覺得可能我自己也要回顧一下的事情
就是之前我一直在講的
就是存儲上的倉位非常糟
這中間帶了大量韓國槓桿
帶了大量的槓桿是ETF
那麼但是其實實際的情況是
所有AI相關資產的倉位都非常糟
並不光是存儲
存儲尤其糟
那麼在存儲發生踩踏的時候
它會連帶
因為當你做momentum
做AI資產的時候
存儲賣出的時候
它會把其他東西一起賣出
無差別
你比方說
我們待會我講一下
最近傳的幾個比較多的事情
比方說在光和CPU上面
這些穿了比較多的事情
然後我先領用一下
比方說那個台積電的Coup
那台積電Coup傳的它不好
然後那其實以後要用更加
那個高質量的光源
那240,000
240,000 PAM4的
其實對momentum更好
但昨天為什麼像最近一段時間
momentum也是在跌
因為它在這個momentum裡面
就是它在這個池子裡面
當這個池子被大規模賣光
或去槓桿的時候
它就不太能倖存
就這個東西和08年高盛
在唯一一個賺錢的公司
在Financial Crisis的時候
也跌了一套營養道理
那麼這個是它本質的原因
那為什麼會導致momentum
吹得開聲完
我覺得大部分是兩件事情
第一個
為什麼它上漲得長得這麼兇
第一個就是半導體公司
確實盈利都非常好
然後盈利非常好
形成它能夠上漲的基礎
那麼第二個
因為它非常賺錢
它不這麼融資
也就是股票
我反覆講
這個東西不光是看估值
我應該值多少錢
股票本質還是要看供需的
就是股票的供應
和股票的錢
對股票的需求
半導體公司沒有特別多的融資
看到之前有一些融資
比方說英特爾
包括Lomanton Coherent
包括康寧
他們去融資
他們是內部銷化的
就我這個Gelatoz Nevidian給的
然後它並沒有在市場上
非常大規模穿的融資
那個Azirimus去融了一把
因為它是新上市融了一把
但是沒有看到半導體公司
如此大規模像
比方說Hyperscale這樣
或者是像其他的那些公司
這樣去融資
所以供應相對比較少
業績非常非常的好
業績增長非常非常快
然後AI的概念很好
那前進去供需矛盾完全被扭曲了
而且今年4月份的時候
我們曾經講過
流動性起始屬於非常非常好的狀態
因為ESLA放開
然後銀行去銅桿
銀行接著流動性遠遠
銀行接著那個Funday rate遠遠低於
比方說5Funday rate
那麼導致流動性就湧到那個
當口上面去
那麼在前兩個星期發生的事情
是我覺得第一個過高
就長的也不是過高吧
很多的估值也並不是說一定很高
其實半導體
我是個人感覺值這個價錢
特別在當前這個東西
確實是值這個價錢
那麼
但是短期裡面長出了幾個C個碼
35個C個碼
然後這種時候
它往往會要回調
用很多獲利盤要出來了
那麼第二個就是海利市去融資去了
海利市它不是融資
它開了EDR
但是它開EDR它大概融了有43萬億韓元
我剛剛有說美人是250個別領
就25個別領
25個別領
然後這筆錢是需要從相信AI的
那個LongLag Momentum
裡面去給套出來的
那原來是帶著槓桿
就吃個人完
吃個就導致了它的這個平常
那麼所以這一輪的平常時候
很明顯的一個趨勢是
就是你沒有看到
現在情況下
你其實沒有看到整個指數Vix上升
昨天晚上指數Vix有點上升
那這是我們待會講
變化中間的一個問題
就是指數沒有看到Vix很高
然後指數也沒有跌很多
指數幾乎是持平
但是半導體暴跌
然後在半導體另外一邊的IGV
就主要說那個軟件這些東西開始翻坦
因為大家平常
也就是你看這些量化基金
它在踩踏的時候
不一定是量化
我們叫Momentum Factor Trade
這些東西在踩踏的時候
它的分控
你要看這比方說
如果是它量化的話
它的分控和它的止損
現在根據是什麼
根據的是它本身倉位的變化
它本身倉位變化被兩邊傻的
所以你不光是3米的Vol
甚至3米的波動率上升
你是3米波動率上升
加上那個軟件波動率上升
因為軟件另外一方波動率上升
它不是兩個Vol合起來
它不算那個關鍵度的
因為它變兩邊傻
所以它的本身倉位的波動會更大
它倉位的波動率是屬於
就是遠遠高於3米本身的
那這個情況下
它就是要波動率上升
它本身就要平常
第二個就是倉位回調
它要平常
所以這個平常第一波是頻掉了
Momentum Trade中間Lang show lag
就是我做了Lang和做了Show
這個方式
這個是先平常
所以這一部分平常有
我們先看一下這個情況
它有沒有結束
我覺得大部分沒有完全結束
結束了可能一半不到
這個是事實
那第二波可能會發生的平常
就是滿倉都在做存儲
或者是在做AI的那些人
那他們有可能會減倉
然後第三波是
他們其實還沒有滿倉的人
回調太多
他可能會需要再減倉
但是這種就我們叫做delabbage下殺
delabbage就去槓桿下殺
去槓桿下殺
delabbage的越多的時候
它的收益越低
收益就是你表去做空
或者你拋盤
或者你直存
這個直存能指調多少存
就是這個你去幹這個行為的收益越低
因為你在往下delabbage上面減倉的人
它下面會減回來
然後沒有滿倉的人
它不一定是去把倉位給拼掉
它有可能加倉的
因為半導體本身
有一個問題
就是半導體的這些公司在2個星期左右
3個星期的時候
他都要去報收益的報二年
然後可見的二年都很好
所以當你現在在delabbage的時候
delabbage是大家不敢買
因為有很多靴子沒落地
那個昨天我昨天晚上
我看那個Wash
又發了比較陰派的言論
大家擔心他
是不是在星期五的時候
直接給你加一次息
他哪怕星期五直接加一次息
後面他加息的幅度也會變小
其實他就嚇走你一下
比方說會不會直接加一次息
那這些美聯儲決策沒有出
然後hyperscale再下一個星期
23號到8月1號這個星期
大公司要報業績
我下面到底做了多少開放
怎麼沒有出
然後那個大部分半導體公司的業績
也沒有報
業績沒報
其實不是看業績都很好
主要是看他後面的Forward looking遠期
所以也沒有出來
然後中間有無數的鬼故事
現在因為大家不敢買
在這個當口裡面
他下沙是很快的
但是為什麼我說收益越來越低呢
因為你跌得越多的時候
你到了一個位置
比方說現在海底石到了180萬
180萬海員
然後180萬海員
他會覺得我
我也會覺得我現在買進去
可能幾個月
我肯定會回來
幾個月
哪怕你在跌三十
他那一輪反彈至少能反倒我
現在買進去的價錢
我不會虧錢
所以會有這樣的資金買進去
所以你其實在接delaveraged的非刀的時候
如果要不就別借
如果覺得要去接delaveraged非刀
你要知道自己是不會借到底
也不用去想借到底的事情
就這個價錢是不是OK
和我可能和Wallin Buffett
你這種想法是一樣
就一定價錢是不到
都OK
那麼在接和不接的時候
我覺得去分析的是
後面兩方面的風險
我總結下面後面兩方面的風險
和現在的狀態
現在是不是已經全部去槓桿完成
首先你看一下
就是第一個觀察的標的標點是說
我現在在硬件在跌的時候
軟件還在漲嗎
所以硬件昨天在跌軟件還在漲
比方說now
我們之前講的軟件
軟件cloth strike
然後我們沒有注意看Palantir和Palotto
我覺得可能也在漲
所以漲的幅度沒有
像一開始的時候那麼大
所以確實最嚴重的那一批delaveraged
可能是完成了
但是long shot lag的
我們叫long shot parity trade
那些平倉沒有說完全完成
第二個指標
可以看的是這個
就是這個是什麼
就是說call put the skewness
就是我有多強的意願
用一架去買
買入侵機權call起權
和賣出性機權
所以你看比方說在三月份
我們起漲的時候
那麼這個價錢就是skill是差不多的
也就是市場是平衡的
當你去買call option
你就是買那個機權的時候
其實你在槓桿買股票
所以你槓桿買股票
你鋪起權
這個價格要往下掉
其實你就減少了
我就槓桿做空
我不太想槓桿做空
所以你可以這個可以看到
就是在至少在機權市場裡面的
就是兩邊的槓桿的程度
那我覺得是現在還是明顯 skew to the end
就是那個 skewness
就是這個期權的波動率
Iv也就implyable的這個架構
是更傾向於現在還處於
有比較多的買入就是那個多頭的槓桿
沒有完全清乾淨
完全清乾淨的時候
你可以看到是這樣的
逆向完全清乾淨
是疫情的時候
你看這個call幾乎是無人問津
然後put大家拼命的
那個是逆向的清乾淨
3月份的時候
包括25年年中的那次大反彈
那個4月份的次大反彈在這裡
是處於這樣的架構
那個4月份也是
我記得那個時候是terrific關稅站
所以關稅站的時候
也是兩邊逆向反的
那麼現在是屬於剛好回來
所以你說是不是這個
就是我們叫做去槓桿藏位完成了
去槓桿並沒有完全完成
但是我這麼說
就是不是每一次發生去槓桿
它都要把槓桿完全去掉的
你可以看過去很多很多次
這個是一個wall上面去看
但是你可以本身也可以看槓桿盤
它其實每一次去
它都有不確定性
去到多少都有不確定性
因為最終你再往下跌
就會有一個問題
敢不敢接這股票
不光是取決於這股票價格
是不是漲了五倍十倍
股票價格是漲了五倍十倍
還取決於這公司的盈利
其實漲得更誇張
盈利預期也漲得更誇張
所以不能柯州求建的
就看我們今天漲了很多
我要把這槓桿全去掉
不太一樣
就是你如果是完全不強行來的
那你就認為它一定要去的
一定要去的就要打回
把這個東西槓桿盤全部拿掉
但是公司每個東西的基本面
其實在過去模型推出以後
我剛好也會說一下
我對模型的感受
模型推出以後是有本質區別
並合並化
所以這個不完全
我不認為一定會去乾淨
所以這是你看現在的狀態
第二個問題是說
我補充說一下
包括海利市
因為有很多中國人感興趣
你們可能也在看中國的股票
海利市發生的事情
把多頭的錢給套出來
去買了他的ADR
然後一下子弄了很多錢
然後再加上
Global有很多的因素
包括各方面的因素
缺個了這個
你看中正五
中正兩千
最近發生的事情一模一樣
就是你接下去要搞長興
搞長興
你也是同樣一批信仰的錢拿出去的
所以中正兩千也會跌
所以你看到我們業界很好的
小公子們跌成像果一樣
他就應該跌成像果一樣
就是它是一個
你應該知道它是量化缺廣感
量化缺廣感前幾年發生過
所以這個你回顧一下
大家都知道
然後接下去
現在我們處於這個狀態
就是有沒有結束這件事情
後面有什麼樣的一個額外的風險
我就說兩個額外的風險
第一個就是Vx其實沒有反彈
這個不是Vx
這個是跟Vx差不多相關的
我們叫做SMP的Vol
這個SMP的correlation
correlation很低導致整個Vx沒有反彈
那correlation很低
關聯度很低
很簡單嗎
你的軟件在漲
硬件在跌
所以你整個波動率沒有上升
因為軟件在漲完
這兩個東西關聯度很低
關聯度已經低到歷史低位
這是最低的時候
現在是利關聯度最低的時候
所以關聯度往後
當它平盤的交易結束的時候
只有兩種可能
一個是正常化
就我現在不平盤
平常結束
正常
然後軟件開漲
該跌跌跌回去一點
硬件開漲漲回去一點
關聯度在一個低位
第二種是關聯度上升
關聯度大規模上升
這個意味著Vx上升
那就是大家一起跌
一起再跌一輪
所以如果是發生一起再跌一輪
那我覺得這個是絕對的
就是對於硬件短期來說是絕對的
因為近期的讓我對模型有信心很多
到我掃出來一波
因為我覺得模型好很多
所以把這個拋開
就我們說
就是這個是整個波動率架構
你可以看到波動率的Single Stop的一甲
這個上次我們就講過了
Single Stop的一甲很大
就是你雖然看到整體的S&P的Vx沒有變化
但是每個公司的波都很大
它只是合在一起不高
合在一起不高
因為它有個叫Coloration Matrix
就是關聯度的矩陣
這個矩陣低
那麼什麼情況下會導致我們的Vx上升
或者Coloration上升
其實現在有兩方面的原因
第一個是現在在NecroGama
這個事情我們講過很多次
就是如果繼續下跌
NecroGama意味著
投行的對同盤是賣出來的
第二個CTA還沒有賣
CTA1000多億
這個數據可能有點老了
這個是老的找
一人就有點老
可能1000億
就是往後可能有
如果是下跌很多的case
上漲的話
它是買入行
買入500億還是600億
買入600億一個月
然後如果是下跌的話
它是賣出1000
這風險不是很對稱
在美國的話大概是500多億
這個對現在沒有跌的票的影響
肯定比跌國的票影響大很多
因為你想它抽出500億
美國大抽500多億
你才一個月抽500億
你現在海利市
你一天就給我搞掉251
所以251還是全部從多頭倉位裡面
從Momentum那個倉位裡出的
所以你這個500億
在美股賣出
它是平均在
包括Apple這些都要一起賣的
所以你會發現
那一輪會一起下跌
但是福特威根會像現在這麼猛
跌得比較兇的
有可能是現在漲的票
就是這種情況如果發生的話
就是Vix上升
CTA賣出
帶著NectarGama一起砸下來
有可能可以讓它繼續跌
但是那個時候是普跌
整個S&P指數要跌的
然後S&P指數要跌的時候
你有可能會發現
今天跌得比較兇的票
這個下降速度沒有那麼快
然後我傾向於覺得
這件事情發生的概率沒有那麼大
不是因為我比較樂觀
主要是因為時間點上
就是大家原來都是比較怕
我也之前比較怕說
7月業績前盡量減倉要漂泡
我已經講了一個月
我當時的看法是認為7月
會出CAPEX會出
會出CAPEX會出安外
所以你CAPEX給多了也不好
給少了也不好
就這個東西就和他們很缺
給因為對於模型
模型能不能賺錢
然後模型收入怎麼樣
大家疑問很大
那麼最近呢
我覺得第一個
anthropy的業績是不錯的
就是他說自己盈利了
叫operating profit 10個億
一個基督10個億
所以看上去
它是把這一部分的擔憂變輕了一點
第二我用下來
我感受GPT的模型就受
這個模型非常好用
又便宜又好用
因為它可能比較聰明
所以它沒有像anthropy
去燒那麼多頭殼
它秒殺中國那些開源模型
就中國開源模型
原來我感受和cloud
可能差不多
在編程方面
跟cloud可能差不多
跟政治有的時候
感覺跟fable差不多
但是GPT有一個叫
autocore的這個模式
它掉用的時候
它掉了很多很多意見
它這個Halix非常強
所以我之前還說的一個問題
就是模型永遠
永遠居住模型是數據
Halix就是它的這個工程
模型本身和算力
這是四個東西疊加
那但是現在感受那個
Obi的這個東西確實是不錯
所以我覺得
可能對整個AI和半導體
或者是整個AI行業
短期裡面更加樂觀一點
業績裡面的大家
因為我模型的問題少了
業績裡面對CAPEX找毛病
第一個模型問題少了
第二個價格本身下降
特別是半導體價錢都下降
所以當正常情況下
價格高的時候
你CAPEX出來怎麼都是不對的
但是當你價格跌過了以後
CAPEX出來
它也很可能變成催化劑
所以據我瞭解
幾家CAPEX都很高
都比較高
像谷歌明年的
明年我知道他內部大概2500億
所以像投行現在預期大概1800左右
但買房有很多貴賣
買房最樂觀預期可能也到這個數
那大家給出明年明確的目標的時候
跌過的半導體是會受到這個催化
所以我傾向於覺得
我們剛剛講那個CASE
就是CTA再賣出Volvo上升
我傾向於時間點上
有可能不一定能夠成功
就不一定能夠再砸這麼大一個課
那麼真的再砸一下
其實對於很多彈性比較大的票
我們彈性大的票就是momentum
就是這些momentum的教育
最壞的時光
我覺得也是過去
就你再砸的話
你可以把最近漲了比較多的
比如說什麼基因利亞
什麼那個帕勞頭
然後那個now service now
然後統一的給你按下去
這個我覺得有可能
那麼但是在把海利是
是怎樣說海利是吧
海利是現在1180億
然後1800萬
然後把1800萬含遠了
去港港的挺厲害的
你要再去港港
給它打到高點下了一半
你瞬間這麼快的下殺到一半
然後沒有反彈
這個不大可能
就是你就算下殺下去
他也會反彈到今天的價格
就這個我覺得
這是市場
沒有一樣東西會一直點
就這個他的受壓的那個受到的壓力
當你受壓全部壓在野生上的時候
你你垮了比較快
然後整體受壓的時候
你垮了沒有那麼的快
然後中間有兩個不確定型
現在另外有三個不確定型
第一個是美聯儲政策
因為我看上去比較強硬
但是不是真的比較強硬
不太知道
我們星期五看
第二個就是伊朗的問題
伊朗問題
我昨天又開始升溫了
是川普真的準備破關子破摔
我剛剛就跟蓋到底
還是他又到時候要踏口
這個不確定
第三個我覺得在經濟層面上面
我們可以去看
而且就是我們可以去看
然後我覺得
這東西還是比較重要
我這個圖上竟然沒有
Cloud沒給我寫上去
我在這裡給你看
這個是CDS spread
過去幾年的CDS spread
所以我們看到現在的CDS
一直在一個D位上面
這個是要引起注意的
也就是現在短期裡面看到CDS
因為我這個事情一個月前說
要買CDS
你要買股票可以
對吧
你要防止極端的風險
真正極端的風險
是這些Hyper Scala
卻要做大量的CAPEX
然後它不夠錢
它要去融資融股票
融股票美是你自己股票點
但是你要去融資借錢的話
你要去融資
你要去借錢的話
那你的CDS又會變寬
CDS變寬它的結果
就融資的稀差
你要借更高你的利息差變寬
利息差變寬是個非常危險的事情
你可以參考Oracle這個股價
和Oracle股價發生以後
應偉大的反應
和所有的半導體的反應
這個才是一個比較危險的東西
然後在Oracle發生問題的時候
其實整體的CDS
甚至沒有抬得很高的
這個位置應該是
就去年年底吧
這個位置還在這
差不多今年年底
現在抬頭屬於一個非常
整體的抬頭
我覺得是一個非常小的幅度
現在還是一個非常小的幅度
但是面臨的未來的融資規模
特別是在大公司
這不是DBBL
就是這大公司裡面非常的大
在Hyper Scaler裡面非常大
所以你如果回去看過去一個月
Hyper Scaler他們特別是亞馬遜融資之後
Hyper Scaler的CDS往上跑的幅度速度
整體的CDS的Widen大概在20個BIP左右
這個幅度已經很恐怖了
你已經能夠看到這個直線的往上跑
這個是AI相關的
所以我個人覺得吧
如果真的AI Trade的發生問題
它會來自於兩個部分
你一個問題就是模型的
你覺得模型有沒有問題
我現在感覺模型
這次做出來以後我會放心一些
加上那個Anthopic的這個收錄
就是可能讓市場會放心一些
就是AI確實能夠帶來生產力
然後這些模型看上去過了一關
那未來繼續永遠沒關過也不可能
就是反正這一關暫時先過
就是模型的問題
第二個就是
扶植這些模型幫它舖算力的
這些Hyper Scaler大廠
它的融資哪裡來
它的融資會不會導致它信用的問題
這個是第二個問題
所以這中間包括兩個sub
就是兩個字極問題
就是我Kappax投多少
DIO ROI多少
我投資收益多少
然後綜合起來
大家評判
是不是願意借錢給你
願意借錢給你的成本是多少
至少現在市場看上去是
對於亞馬遜只容200多億
261萬下
只容200多億的反應相當於滿名感
但是包括我們看到
對韓國人的反應也滿名感
就對韓國這個市場的反應
你猜容了200多億
然後整個市場這樣子
那麼我們接下去市場
可是要容幾千億投
這個幾個Hyper Scaler出來要容幾千億
明年還要容5千億
所以我說什麼
就是之前我講了一個話
就是我們之前開的是平坦的路
不是說不能開
這些公司營利都很好
而且這些公司
我們說半導體的公司
它其實是它們不怎麼融資的
那麼只是說往前的路上
可能是傑賓的路
你要開車要小心
就是這麼一個說法
所以我總體來講一下吧
就是現在在短線面
有很多很多鬼故事
半導體我覺得這個整個行業
它的營利不受影響
現在我們又看到營利受影響的跡象
主要的風險
主要這一次發生的問題
在momentum trade在平倉
這是市場投存的問題
這個平倉不一定會走完
但是這個平倉沒有走完
但是它不一定會真的走完
後面真正的風險
我覺得就是在第一個
就是宏灣層面
波動率VIX變高
就是它的關聯度變高
然後第二個風險就在CDS
就是我們整體的信貸
信貸會出問題
這個問題是需要去對沖的
就CDS你的問題是對沖的
你不對沖的話
這個是真的有可能會保的
那麼如果是波動率VIX上升
導致了CTA賣出導致了Gama賣出
這些也會是一個短期的
所以到你對沖不對沖
我覺得還好
好吧
我大致這樣說一下
然後今天時間可能用了比較長
我就我就我就不做Q&A了
好吧
謝謝大家
沒有什麼問題
我就先站了
謝謝大家